[Music]
[Applause]
uh joe thomas nfl network analyst former
brown's ten time pro bowl offensive
tackle you can follow him on twitter at
joe thomas73
the 2021 thursday night football
schedule kicks off
week two giants redskins washington
football team
on nfl network joe when you played how
much did you care about the schedule
when it was released
it was a big deal for me i was a little
bit heavier than i
am right now and i just wanted to make
sure that we weren't opening up in
september in florida anywhere because i
knew that was going to be absolutely
dreadful
and then actually one of the other
things that i look for i did not like
playing on turf as my body was breaking
down later in my career
every time we had a turf game on that
schedule i was looking forward to being
able to check that off
and not having to do that one again so
uh
it was all about the pain and misery
that my body was going to go through
that was the first thing that my eyes
went to with the schedule release
worst playing field you ever played on
honestly the old buffalo bills stadium
it was not quite
astroturf but it was just one step above
astroturf
and it was so hard and it left you sore
at least through the next sunday
yeah a lot of people talked about the
the vet in philadelphia
but i don't the old vet i don't know if
you got a chance to play on that but
there were a lot of players who said
when
you fell on that turf it was like it was
like green colored cement
yeah exactly i never played on the vet
but camp randall stadium
when i was a true freshman at wisconsin
they had that old astroturf that was
really brutal and you come out of that
game and you would have
no skin left on your elbows and on your
knees but
i did play at the meadowlands before the
new york football team's
transitioned to their new home and that
was a pretty tough stadium
but even more than the field was the
locker room the locker room was like
those old school
high school gym lockers where you had
like the mesh metal and everything
would you know you'd put the lock over
there and then
everybody was sharing those wooden
benches and then you know there's maybe
20 showers but only
five of them work and only three out of
those five actually have hot water
and then you look around there's five
guys under one shower head
that's not weird right got a little
awkward in those moments
no quick movements no quick movements uh
what stood out
last night with this schedule release
well as a browns fan i love that
first game for the browns going to
kansas city where their season ended
last season in the playoffs
the browns are probably going to have
nine new starters on defense
and so this is going to be their
measuring stick right you could talk
about how great the defense is
going to be this season and how it's
been overhauled and they're going to be
a team that can finally win a
championship well
hey week one you gotta test you're gonna
go and play the kansas city chiefs
the best offense in the nfl over the
last several seasons so that was the
first one
that stuck out for me yeah but also do
you want that test right out of the gate
if you're the browns you know can't
going to kansas city
i'm not saying that if i was on the
bronze that was the game that i wanted
to start with but as a fan
that was the one that stuck out but
certainly if they come out of that game
and they're able to hold that kansas
city chiefs offense down a little bit
i mean they really should feel great
about themselves
and great about the things that they
were able to build through the offseason
and actually it comes at a good point
because
if you think about the browns defense
completely overhauled
they're not going to show their stuff in
preseason but the browns defense is
going to have an advantage because
they kind of know what the chief's
offense is going to look like so really
if you do have to face the chiefs
offense it's probably good for this
browns defense to do it in week one
where they can have that element of
surprise
do you think there's any questions about
baker mayfield
being the future quarterback with the
cleveland browns
i don't think there's questions about
him being the future there's certainly
questions about how high the ceiling is
i think he showed last year
he's their franchise guy he's the guy
that they can build around
but where is that ceiling can he become
one of those top five quarterbacks
or is he going to be sort of a you know
10 to 15
range quarterback where he's really good
you don't have to pay him at the top of
the market so you kind of build around
him
or is he going to be like aaron rodgers
russell wilson where
he can lead a team by himself and you
don't necessarily have to worry about
the pieces quite as much
yeah i just wonder because i i want to
see another season before i'm going to
give him 100 million dollars
and it feels like that next quarterback
up it just makes more than the previous
quarterback
like to me it's financial insanity
because baker mayfield is
not patrick mahomes or he's not aaron
rodger i mean he's not these russell
wilson
but he's going to be paid a whole lot
more than those guys that's the part
that would make me nervous
unless you think there's a sweet spot
where you go you know what he's a 25
million
a year quarterback if if we can both
agree on that
both sides then i think that that can
work out in the long term for both
but i don't know if you know these
agents go no you deserve 40 million
you're as good as dak prescott like
that's that's where things get a little
tricky joe
yeah well it's a factor of two things
one obviously it's the escalating salary
cap because the tv money keeps going up
but two i think what you're seeing is
that teams are slowly realizing
and slowly uh adapting to the fact that
the quarterback in today's nfl is more
important to the team's success than
ever before so they should capture
an ever greater portion of the salary
cap
and that's why you're seeing these
quarterback contracts for guys that
aren't the best
quarterback in the nfl maybe it's those
you know even middle of the range
starters
they're still so important to the
success of the team that that's why
they're getting those huge contracts and
coaches
and gm's they're in a bind right if they
lose their franchise quarterback they
realize they're probably two years from
getting fired so
they've got the gun to their head when
they are in those contract negotiations
with agents
how would you feel if you were a pro
bowl lineman with the packers right now
i'd be very nervous because i know that
our team is going to be a lot different
with aaron rodgers
under center than it is maybe jordan
love or anybody else
and now i i could maybe think wow
you know taking sides here who's right
who's wrong but in the end
i'm thinking hey this team has a chance
to win a super bowl with aaron rodgers
and if he walks out the door for
whoever's fault
we may be in a little bit of trouble and
we may struggle to become
a winning team in 2021 but would you
have a say
in anything as a all-pro offensive
lineman future hall of famer could you
go to management
and ask questions could you go to
management and say
hey i played against this guy in free
agency you know he's great
or hey don't sign that guy i didn't
think he was that good like are you
allowed to have that
i think when you've been around long
enough and you've had enough success at
your position
any smart front office but did you do
this with cleveland
i didn't go out of my way because i
didn't have to dan like they were coming
to me and saying
hey what do you think about this guy hey
this is a pass rusher that's going to be
on the market
we're looking to add a defensive end
what did you think about them give us
your
five-minute scouting report because they
value information
and i think that's what any good gm is
going to do he's not locking himself in
a room and watching film
he's going out and he's asking all the
people that he has in his scouting
department all the coaches
trying to gather information on all
those players before they go out and
ultimately he makes the decision
did they ever ask you your opinion on
quarterbacks
no because i don't really have a very
good sense of what makes a great
quarterback
other than what everybody else does like
i can see
okay he's a great leader he throws a
nice pass he makes good decisions he's
got a nice snap count so i can get out
of my stance on time
but as far as like the intricacies of
deciding
when and where to throw the football i
don't understand the coverages and the
and the the way a quarterback needs to
read a defense well enough to be able to
say
this guy is better than you know this
other starter that's potentially out
there
if you were on the jags what would your
feeling be about tim tebow getting a
chance
you know it would be a little bit
lukewarm i i think from
a player's standpoint you're going to
see the tim tebow circus coming to town
and
as a player you just kind of want to
avoid some of that in general because
you just want to focus on your job you
don't want to focus on the shenanigans
that comes
when you sign tim tebow but on the other
hand you're kind of thinking maybe if
i'm trevor lawrence
hey this takes a little bit of pressure
off me now they're going to be asking me
about tim
tebow rather than hey why'd you screw up
the snap count why did
everybody move and you weren't ready for
the snap or hey why did you throw the
ball into the dirt
three times in a row in that scrimmage
so it does alleviate i think
some of the pressure off the young guys
but maybe some of the older guys
especially those skill guys they tend to
have a little bit bigger egos they like
to
have the attention on them and when that
attention is on your fourth string tight
end
i can see that that would maybe be a
little bit of a stone in your underwear
but it's 90 player roster then it gets
down to
53 on game day i mean that's a big leap
there
and i think people are claiming he's
going to make the roster
yeah but i think people like they're
angry about this former players are
angry that
tebow doesn't deserve this he's
polarizing
i think urban is just doing him a favor
come on in
and you know this might be your last
hurrah and then maybe you join my staff
as uh you know as a coach i don't see
him playing
no the people that are angry are way off
base because first of all
nfl teams have been asking tim tebow
since he was basically run out of the
league as a quarterback to hey
we'd love to bring you back if you want
to try tight end because they realize
that he's got a great work
work ethic and he's a guy that
could potentially be a good locker room
player because he does the little things
right as a professional
and let's be honest that fourth string
tight end job in the nfl
it's kind of like the uh the position of
assistant to the manager
if you run a company where it's not
really all that important
you're probably not going to see the
field and you know what if your cousin's
looking for a job you can give them that
job because it really in the end
it doesn't really matter who has that
position because it's not critical to
the success or failure of the team or
the business
uh you were called for holding you know
how many times you were called for
holding in your career
i don't i don't believe i ever was steve
okay now that i now that i remember
they flagged somebody wearing number 73
17 times in your career
how many times do you think you actually
held in your career
you know the the conversation on holding
is so funny because i think the
general fan thinks that holding is like
when you take your hands and you grab
somebody's jersey but when those nfl
officials would actually come in and
talk to us
they talked much more about your feet
and where your feet was in relation to
your defender
and if your defender was beyond you and
has beaten you and then you grab them
and then hold them and then
stop their ability to get to the ball
carrier that's technically what
gets called for holding from a flag so i
don't remember ever being beat and
having to grab and hold
my player in if that is the exact
question that you're asking yeah but
it's kind of like
hooking somebody like you can make
yourself look
guilty but if you do it in sort of the
context of saying hey we're going to let
you do this
the defender knows we're going to let
you do this just don't do this
or you're going to get flagged so you
sort of know what the ground rules are
yeah as a lineman you know like
obviously like i just mentioned you know
the ground rules are
don't get your feet beat and then grab
and restrain that player
and their ability to get to the ball
carrier but i i think it's interesting
when i watch these guys out there
they're actually not holding in a lot of
cases but the ball runs past them
and then instead of just letting them go
and acting like nothing happened
you know the first thing they do is they
throw their hands up in the air like i'm
not holding anymore
and even if they weren't holding a lot
of times the ref sees him acting guilty
and he throws the flag
and it just drives me nuts you see those
young tight ends do it more than anybody
else because they haven't yet realized
that
as soon as you throw your hands in the
air like oh i'm not guilty
that's when the flag comes but who is
mad at you what what
you know edge rusher
you know what some of them have gotten
mad at me over the over the years but
i think that there was a pretty healthy
respect amongst
most of the guys that i went against the
guys that i had the biggest beef with
usually were those guys like linebackers
that you didn't see
all that often but that would get really
pissed off if you were peeling them off
a pile or you were
kind of giving them that extra shove as
the ball carrier went by
those were usually guys that i ended up
beefing with but the players like you
know the
the james harrisons and the terrell
suggs that you're going against
every single player for 65 plays there's
a healthy understanding of like what i
need to do to get my job done
and what you need to do to get your job
done and
they get it like if i beat them and i
pancake them and i land on top of them
they shouldn't have got beat in the
first place yeah but if you go with
their legs though
that's when it's different right when
you're well that's dirty right you know
if if if you're trying to go with their
legs especially from the side or the
back
like totally understand them getting
upset because
you're going after their livelihood like
they are picturing their children
and their wife and like if they get hurt
especially a guy that doesn't have a big
guarantee contract like
they could be it for their nfl career so
they've got to be able to protect their
family
also and and going dirty and trying to
injure a guy like that
i i don't think that has any place in
the game and i'd get pissed for them
but it doesn't like they don't have
things at the bottom of the pile anymore
like you guys have cleaned up your act
when
you get into that scrum and guys are
grabbing and
there's still some of that when you're
tr the only time it really happens dan
is if
there's a fumble right and and somebody
jumps on it and
when they're in that kind of like baby
cradle position it's really hard to get
the ball out
and so there's a little bit of you know
eye gouging and poking and you know
stuff like that but grabbing the groin
though
help me understand that so the last time
that happened actually
um it didn't happen to me thankfully it
happened to alex mack he was our center
in cleveland and
sean smith i think it was he was playing
for the chiefs at the time
and there was some uh some crotch
grabbing going on at the bottom of a
pile
and actually it worked in the chief's
favor though because alex got right up
and i think he tried to punch on right
in the face got a 15-yard penalty and so
that was sort of the moral of that story
like hey even if somebody goes for the
crotch grab
you can't get that mad you just wait
till the next play and then try to get
him back because if you try to retaliate
right there when the ref is uh standing
there it's not gonna end up well for you
they're gonna get you
hey great to talk to you joe thanks for
joining us uh and uh have fun in the off
season
yeah thanks for having me on dan that's
joe thomas the nfl network analyst and a
future hall of fame offensive lineman he
was a pro bowl offensive
tackle 10 years with the cleveland
browns